I am Noah
this is your three-minute bootcamp lower
body workout alright so right now we've
got Noah and he's gonna teach us a
little bit of bootcamp lower body very
glute centric work out here so walk me
through what we're about to do about the
butt right here so it's true bootcamp
we're gonna slow it down a little bit
for a little bit we'll get to the
bootcamp stuff at the end so we're gonna
put that right heel on the floor I want
to really focus on the heel I want to
bring that heel nice and close to our
body we're gonna drive that heel up as
much as we can squeezing that glute and
hamstring really focus on squeezing it
dropping those hips down we're gonna
finish off with a crunch because nobody
objects to doing crunches for 45 seconds
switch legs 45 seconds then bring it
back down we're gonna finish off with
two okay then we're gonna take it just
to our final move now is when we get a
little bootcamp ish Ohio mattress we're
gonna do just our bodyweight now let's
get that heart rate up
let's melt a little fat as we do this
we're gonna do froggy Joe so right here
I want you to go then just walk it back
you can recenter yourself I want to
focus on explosivity and really firing
off of those toes so let's do a start me
up here ice and stuff so right on the
floor this is a good change of pace now
heels on the floor raise one leg up left
leg
45 seconds let's start it up I want you
to squeeze your glute and hamstring that
you bring those hips up so 45 seconds
right there now time we're just gonna
switch over left leg and like I said if
you wanted to put that extra weight if
you don't have a weight you grab
anything put it together both legs
together for after that 45 seconds and
squeeze those glutes
give me a crunch try to keep that chin
off your chest as you come up
really exhaling and focusing on flexing
those that midsection after that 45
seconds right now we're gonna want to
bring it up now now is their lives now
this is my
sometimes you gotta take it slow but
let's do this deep squat from your
course all right as you come down 45
seconds on the clock hit it
let's go that's it this is where I get
comfortable but sometimes you got to
slow it down hit it last and all right
so to recap guys on this glute centric
lower body workouts we start off with
unilateral leg raises forty-five seconds
per side thrown a crunch in there in
between each one and then a bilateral
leg raise with a crunch as well and then
we finished off with 45 seconds of frog
leaves very manly exercise there does
work get your heart rate up works those
glutes those hamstrings
I like this workout thank you know